hey Conan O'Brien here with another
clueless gamer today I'm very excited
cuz I'm gonna be playing the game
cuphead which will be available
exclusively on Xbox September 29th the
game was inspired by 1930s cartoons and
because it features cooperative play
I've decided to team up with someone who
I consider a friend a partner some might
even say a soul mate Kate Upton I'm
surprised by a soul mate I feel like I
was projecting me
I was projecting into the future yeah
right of course once you can see four
minutes into the future yeah that's
great
this is a tradition we have here at
clueless gamer is for years now I've
been playing these video games with big
celebrities before we play the game we
unwind a little bit just enjoy
yourselves this is something we do all
the time okay
so just come with me if you don't want
yeah have a seat right there listener
for - yeah just little song for you
thank you yeah that's fine you can have
as much as that isn't what okay Antonio
[Music]
Ateneo that's enough I think no no every
single person has played with oh but
kind of removed did that with Tom Brady
he hit me maybe we should get back to
the game yeah let's play a video game
okay look at that look at that they made
a special Conan O'Brien selection screen
decide you have to do something very
dumb and boring first okay yeah Utah can
you believe what a nerd this guy is
right not like us yeah cool cool and
beautiful people what's it like nerd
you're the red I'm the blue okay I'm the
blue yes I'm blue I'm shooting I'm
shooting I'm shooting wait what happened
you died I died yes wait Kate's fine and
I died yes oh you were playing for like
six seconds
[Music]
awful okay this is Becky the clown now
we're fighting this is great I feel like
you and I are in a real synergy yeah you
know what I mean we are now where's the
part where we just hug like we're happy
and I come near you just seem to hug you
there's a lot happening right now sort
of like in the throes of passion when
you just let yourself go whatever
happens happens
Oh baseball's are on here just like my
Beyonce you never told me about your
fiance
why would you meet me in a warehouse to
play a video game if you have a fiance
you tell I'm wearing Cologne okay no
it's a body spray it's not by accident
company that normally makes spray paint
[Music]
hey Kate yeah can I just suggest that
maybe we both use the same controller
that might help us do better just you
just hold it you hold it and then I hold
it too and then we work together wait
shoot shoot what stop yelling at me you
make me nervous I don't perform as well
wait just a little bit down okay hold
this down right here I am oh look at
that look at that look at that nice yes
yes you could take your other hand and
put it like on top of my hand if you
want
I smell that cool now maybe your fiancee
would like to know what this brand is
huh look at that I'm trying to jump on
top of those things yeah what happened I
think we won did we win
look what happened when I just knew you
were probably it wasn't your idea yeah
when I suggested that we work together
our bodies touching it felt like we
became one person yeah I was able to
help you experience winning okay I've
done a lot of clues gamers and I just
got I got a little nervous about this
one and I apologize if in any way I made
this an awkward situation for you the
won't happen again
[Music]
[Applause]
well the game is called cuphead it's
really fun to play with a loved one or
just an incredibly beautiful woman or
friend or friend who thinks you're an
asexual freak
[Applause]
you